forte mobilisation dans l'enseignement
ce mardi en france et dans les yvelines
pour le report de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
parmi les grévistes ces deux enseignants
non syndiqués de l'école élémentaire
paul fort de montigny le bretonneux le
manque de concertation
c'est ce qui les agace le puits mais
pourquoi on n'arrive vraiment pas à
faire en sorte de laisser du temps aux
gens pour se concerter pour se mettre
d'accord sur un certain nombre de points
et que ses idées sans être édulcoré sans
être censuré ou qu'on les vider de leur
substance alimente une loi et que ce
soit vraiment quelque chose qui emporte
l'adhésion passionnés par leur métier
ils sont conscients de la nécessité
d'une réforme dans l'intérêt de l'enfant
l'idée du corps enseignant reporter la
réforme payant à la rentrée 2014 afin de
réécrire le décret on doit repenser les
rythmes scolaires sur la journée sur la
semaine mais également sur l'année il ya
beaucoup de problèmes qui sont pas
résolus à l'heure actuelle à savoir les
activités qui seront proposées sur le
cadre périscolaire
quelle formation encadrée par quel
personnel une question de locaux qui se
pose également
bref on se pose la question parce qu'on
n'a pas non plus envie qu'eux temps
périscolaire se transforme en garden
pour ces enseignants rien ne garantit
actuellement la qualité et la gratuité
du temps périscolaire
pas de précision non plus sur les
programmes pourtant jugée lourde et
inadaptée selon le syndicat ces nuitées
pib ligne les taux de grévistes
s'élevait à près de 60% ce mardi dans le
département
150 écoles sur 1000 seraient fermés à
saint quentin en yvelines une grève
massivement suivie notamment à montigny
le bretonneux elancourt guyancourt et la
verrière attrape 30 écoles sur 36
étaient fermés ce mardi à la mairie une
centaine d'enseignants de la ville a
fait entendre ses inquiétudes
elle peut pas laisser une réforme est
financé par les collectivités
locale parce que là c'est l'inégalité
assurer un c'est voilà donc ça c'est ça
c'est insupportable sur trappe
évidemment on fera pas payer les
activités mais il ya des petites
communes où on élève les impôts locaux
ont fait payer les activités le coût de
la réforme à la mairie de montigny le
bretonneux
on l'a d'ores et déjà estimé un million
et demi d'euros par an